Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David P,
here's a voicemail from a conspiracy theorist
who goes by the name Total Control. This is an
exercise in caution. This is what can happen
when your brain is on conspiracy theories.
Speaker 2: Hey, Dave, it's
me. Total control. 871. I
know it's been a while, right? I didn't want all
of 20, 22 to slip by without you knowing that I'm
still alive. I know. I know. You're just killing
yourself right now, right? But I still have the
same question. I think the last time I called
and put on your voicemail. Why am I still alive?
I never take a single injection. I never use a
face diaper. I never socially distance. And yet
I keep on living just fine. Not even a head cold.
Wow. And nobody around me is getting sick either.
So. Hey, Dave, I'm just calling to find out. How
come? Well, I guess this will make this the third
prediction of severe winter of illness and death.
And we're up to triple them now. Right. First
it was ten them acknowledged triple them.
Speaker 1: You know, it's interesting. Just
speak. It's sort of like I don't know,
they keep talking about car accidents,
but I've been driving for 20 years and I'm
alive. So there must really be nobody dying
in car accident. It's very, very dumb.
Speaker 2: What's it going to be next
winter? Yeah. Quadruple down neck. I don't
know. What can I say? Seems to me like nobody
can ever keep it straight. Because, you know, it's
evolving with the rolling of the eyes. But anyway,
I'm still here. I'm still kickin. All right.
Speaker 1: Well, total control hasn't died. And
he wants us to know that despite despite
not being vaccinated. And, of course,
that is the very, very scary mind of a conspiracy
theorist, for lack of a better term. We've got a
fantastic bonus show for you today.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show,
if you want to make money and everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah, we're going to make money on
the bonus show today with the following topics.
We are going to talk about House Republicans
taking as one of their first actions yesterday,
removing the metal detectors from the House floor.
Okay. We'll talk about what they're doing. Tobacco
companies in Spain are being billed for the clean
up of cigaret butts. This is very interesting. And
we will also talk about the number of children in
the United States who accidentally eight cannabis
edibles in 2021. And does this vindicate
the claims of the anti cannabis right wing?
Hint it does not. We will talk
about all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show. Get access
to instantly. Not in an hour, not in a
day. Get access instantly by signing.
Unidentified: Up at join pack and.